[Music]
welcome people good morning happy
thanksgiving
great day today uh we're joining about
30 minutes late
to the coverage of the day two of the
skilling knockout stage
um i apologize for the delay but uh we
we won't miss the
the match deciding portion the last
three games
uh well i'm glad to hear that h wilson
and uh like i said i wanted to cover
this event and
today is the first day that i sort of
feasibly can
and hikara will have to beat mvl in
their matchup today and then they will
move on to the the armageddon playoff
carlson beat geary in yesterday's
matchup here we have geary against
carlson in their first game of the day
so we had another italian an italian
stallion we have one two three four
five against one two three four so gary
is up a pawn
but there's a couple mitigating factors
here uh obviously his kingside pawn
structure is completely ruined which
lessens the effect of the extra pawn i
wouldn't be looking at the extra pawn
here to evaluate this position
i would be looking more at the king
safety because it's very clear that i
think the king safety is what's going to
be deciding this game
and it's not clear to me right off the
bat whose king is weaker both gangs are
terrible
white's king is directly under fire
gary's probably going to go bishop e3
here try to cover it up at least from
the rook
i don't imagine him going king d2
although maybe he will
um and oh bishop e5 okay so he
takes a slightly more aggressive stance
the downside of this move thank you
melancia the downside of this move
is that this bishop is is only supported
by a pawn on t4 and this pawn
on d4 can potentially be undermined with
a move such as c5
so geary he has to act fast
if he makes a sloppy move like queen c6
trying to trade queens
and carlson takes and takes on d4 and
because of the pin
uh he's he's going to pick up a lot of
material
but giri's got to be extremely careful
in this position maybe he considers f4
but the problem with that move
well that yields another uh huge square
for the black queen this is a critical
moment
two minutes and a half for gary to
decide what to do bishop b5 i'm not sure
about that just seemed
maybe a little bit too audacious of a
move
um rook c6 is interesting
but i'm not sure exactly what that
accomplishes the funny thing is black
could even go queen f5
and it looks like he walks right into a
pin but the reality is after queen f6
remember that white's bishop is the one
that's pinned sorry walks into a fork
but
white's bishop is pinned and that really
hurts geary here uh and i'm not sure
he's gonna have the chance to move his
king away from the pin
it may look like a blunder didn't i just
say
that magnus uh has this in store but
then queen takes d5 and gary picks off
the bishop with check
but magnus does it anyway so his idea is
to go queen d5 queen e6
they're going to bail this is going to
be a draw they're just going to bail out
into an endgame now yes white is up a
pawn in this engine but
remember white's got the ruined pawn
structure and really the effect of that
is tremendously lessened
by this ruined pawn structure i'm
anticipating a draw here i'm
anticipating queen d5 queen e6
and then they're going to have
liquidation and could carlson have gone
for one thing to notice though
maybe that's not his idea because gary
can actually take on e6
and then take here and then go this is
probably what's going to happen
carlson's going to be the one fighting
for a draw
yeah so gary's going to take the queen
carlson's going to take
gear he's going to take now what's going
on here the bishop on e5 must be
protected
with f4 now they take and at the end of
the day when the smoke is cleared
this is the position i think that's
going to appear on the board carlson is
now down a full pawn
but giri has to drop his rook back to a
very passive stance
look at how active black's pieces are
pawn count is not the only thing that
decides the evaluation in an end game
it's also all about peace activity so
hopefully oh thank you
ah that's that's really sweet that's
really sweet that's a really sweet
command
all right you guys are going to make me
blush
damn girl i don't think carlson missed
it i think he saw it and he just decided
to go for a draw
akilah is the sweetest i don't know what
gary's thinking
about because the alternative is to go
for this end game and clearly magnus
isn't even worse here
i think gary's trying to figure out what
he missed the answer is nothing
no he does what girl he does go for this
i don't get it
i i think something was missed here
because as far as i know
this at least presents minuscule chances
for white
here you have the same exact position
oh okay so i guess
i guess the same position arises there's
some weird decisions being made by both
players here i'm not sure exactly what's
behind the c5 in this position
maybe i'm getting the wrong read on this
end game but basically at the end of the
day we got exactly the same type of
position that
would have arisen from that variation
except white has extra two pawns
and yet i still believe that this game
is going to end in a draw because
because black's got incredible piece
activity look at how blackstroke ties
down whitestroke to the defense of the
a2 pawn
the king on f5 always threatens to go to
f4 and just vacuum up the rest of
white's king side pawns
so it's very hard for gary to make any
kind of substantive progress here
um thank you whoa holy smokes
fifty dollars what a morning gift and
i'm thankful of course to this community
which i will properly say earlier
i came across your speedrun series on
youtube and couldn't believe this level
of instruction was available for free
well thank you so much crow
for the 50 dono that is amazing stuff
here
thank you so much my man um
that is just incredible thank you so
much
that that's awesome um
that is just absolutely awesome all
right
so absolutely lovely message indeed and
here we go so what is geary doing gary's
saying okay
i'm going to give up some of my pawns
but
i'm going to try to dislodge the stroke
from the f5 i think this is going to
happen
king b4 seems to make the most sense now
rook takes f3 is forced
and then what gary's going to do is make
a play on black's a pawn he's either
going to go rook c5 check but most
probably rook
to c7 is what we're going to see in the
next three seconds
we're about to see rook c7 carlson's
gonna play rook takes hp do not take
this pawn because you lose the rook
carlson's gonna take here carlson could
also consider the move a5 check
which he just played and the idea is
after king takes a5
magnus doesn't take any of these pawns
he returns to take this pawn
because the king is very close to
eliminating these other pawns so gary's
question is does he take the panda's
equal king a4
king a4 seems to be the ambitious
attempt he does end up taking the pawn
aw gm hess is in the chat but rook takes
h7 king g6 and the game ends in the draw
because the rook has to move then rook
takes f2 and black easily picks off the
last remaining point i think gary's just
gonna go h4h5
yeah so the game is a draw very
interesting liquidation there i'm not
sure that
geary well i think the magnus had
everything calculated i think he was
well within
and sorry for the choppiness that's just
how the transmission is coming in
this is a really interesting position
guys i want to uh analyze this a little
bit
dana night or which is mvl specialty
bishop d3 this is a very interesting
move
uh it's become very popular recently in
the united
um and they got this kind of interesting
position where
icaru managed to ruin mvl's pawn
structure and then he like went after
his pawns
yeah he just went after his puns mvl
bishop takes a2 that doesn't look like a
movie play if you're in good shape
and um we got
oh my goodness
oh my freaking goodness this is
unbelievable am i seeing a hundred
dollar dono from spunkel
happy thanksgiving my dude are you
kidding me christmas has come early
indeed
this is absolutely ridiculous i've
barely started commentating
oh my goodness thank you spunkle
happy thanksgiving to you too absolute
poger's level of support this morning
man i don't know what to say that's
awesome that is just awesome stuff thank
you so much man
i really appreciate it um do why did he
karo knuckle b3
um it's a great question actually
why did he car not trap the bishop
fisher style thanks again spunkle that
that's an incredible level of support
i think the reason is king b8 i'm not i
don't turn on the analysis bar or the
engine by the way that's just my my rule
uh by the way
if rook d6 trying to pin the knight to
the queen then queen h3 is the point you
escape
with check then you move the knight away
and then presumably
you go after the bishop this is also not
so clear
but i would say maybe you preemptively
move the king out of the way so that
rook d6 becomes a threat
and um i suppose white can move his
knight away from before but here you can
see that mbl starts to develop this
initiative
and he starts bossing white's pieces
around
so the bishop doesn't tell the whole
story i think that's the reason why
hikara refrained from this
and decided instead to sort of allow
black's bishop back but on the other
hand continues the bishop takes age
seven
a very fearless play here thank you
texas crane for the tier one
and uh a very complicated game i'm sure
this is worthy of far deeper analysis
than i'm subjecting this to
but eventually hikaru just sent his pawn
down down black's throat
and and and there's just no stopping and
now bishop d3 traps the rook on d2 it
can't move anywhere knight e4 is also a
possibility so
this is okay wow they're staggering
these games what what is going on
why is it so hard to follow this
tournament
am i alone here it's like some games are
starting some games are not okay so mvl
hikaru i know is what people are
interested in we have an italian here
this is all theory okay so we just got a
standard italian position oh hikaru had
this
ikaru had this against who did he have
this against i can swear i saw
him having this against somebody that he
lost to i think it was magnus
i think icaru had this against magnus in
their famous matchup
okay so
what do we have here what's going on in
this position well black has a past one
which is a good thing uh but very often
when you look at a pass spawn in the
middle game you want to look at the
square in front of the pass pawn
and try to understand does the opponent
have control over that square because
that is what's called a blockading
square
that was introduced by aaron nimesovich
and white does have
fairly good control thank you arden for
the 500 bits of the d4 square
and he's trying to increase that control
by kicking black's knight away from f5s
that he can potentially position a
knight on d4 but
mvl deciding instead to go after black's
kingside now h5 here by hicara would
keep things closed off
but in that case i think mbl would
eventually want to put a knight on d4
maybe prepare something like e6
um so he's immediately facing hikara
with a a challenge here does he take the
pawn i don't
think that doesn't look good to me
because it it allows the queen to get
very active and attack the knight
so this seems a little bit fishy he
basically offers a queen trade so
if the mbl takes it and now mvl takes
you get an interesting end game i think
white's better here he can try to break
through with e6
i think white's definitely calling the
shots black has quite deficient pawn
structure
and again remember that white has
control over the square in front of the
pass pawn
but hikaru is very good at defending
these kinds of positions
uh and and he rarely loses them mvl
could also play e6 immediately maybe
that's a little over ambitious but i
want to open up files
for my rooks my anticipation and my
estimation he's going to take on h6 and
go e6
but we'll see
no eval bar here that's right all right
the tracks are you have a great
thanksgiving thanks for the five gifted
enjoy the turkey
so i think what if i can try to you know
become a demon and go into the mine of
mbl i think what he's thinking about is
two things do i take on h6 number one
number two do i go e6 and try to open up
the e file for my pieces
the alternative would be something like
i don't knight t4 you know just
bringing the pieces into the game
blockading the pun
and then bringing the rook into the game
that would also be possible but
e6 just seems to be where the turkey's
at no pun intended
uh mvl has decided to trade on h6 and
he's gone a3
so he's decided now to chip away at
the edges rather than mount the frontal
assault with e6 he's keeping e6 in his
pocket
instead deciding to open up some
prospects for the rook on a1
hikaru could try to close things down
with b3 but then that would create the
weakness of the b3 pawn
and bl would attack that with rookie 3
and the pawn would be lost
it's easy to follow that white just wins
the pawn here
so that's not what he carries going to
do what is cicara going to do is he
going to play rook to c2 trying to mount
a counter attack against white spawns
that seems pretty plausible
is he maybe going to try to sacrifice
the pawn on b4 but try to
put a bandaid over some of the other
weaknesses in his position something
like knight to c6 comes to mind
he takes b4 and maybe you don't even
take the pawn maybe you go rook b5 the
idea
is to keep the a7 square under control
so that white doesn't infiltrate with
his rook
he goes rook to c2 so he does play a
move in that spirit
um activating his rook counter-attacking
white's pawn
and um we'll see how how this is handled
by the way carlson gary is underway we
have a grunfeld
with a double fin ghetto carlos or gary
playing e3
a very peaceful move that giri is
obviously huge opening specialist
but against someone like carlson it
makes sense to play something a little
calmer
uh something to hopefully throw magnus
out of his own
incredible preparation that's what these
battles revolve around frequently
etc etc now by the way mbl has now gone
e6 as we
kind of discussed he has played this
move the problem is he's running out of
material
now what is his idea if hikaru just
takes on b4
just says i'm ignoring everything
because if you take on f7 i'll take back
with the rook
and i will defend the knight on e7 mbl
could jump to e5
white is no doubt calling the shots here
i don't think white is risking losing
the game even if he's down upon he's got
such peace activity
he's not going to be in danger of losing
any time soon
but he might not be in danger of winning
the game anytime soon either
because if he runs out of pawns and
hikaru keeps his pieces protected
well uh white might not have enough
prospects here
to mount any sort of meaningful attempt
okay
so we're going to keep an eye on this
carlson geary is proceeding along these
sort of calm grunfeld waters you can see
anish
putting his knights on d-2 this kind of
resembles a hippo
but with the pawns on d4 and c4 that
does not resemble the most ambitious
opening setup i've seen um
and it's quite insane to see magnus
i'm not sure what you mean yeah i mean
i borrowed this from a russian phrase
that where they say like he's not
risking losing but he's also not risking
winning
and gary going oh but carlson is white
sorry i for some reason i confused it
i thought carlson was black so carlson
is actually playing this makes more
sense
it makes more sense that magnus would be
playing a setup like this because he
doesn't need to win
uh today's mini match he just needs to
get a com
geary going h5 so he's stopping any
potential attempt at g4
he's keeping the bishop locked in place
my apologies for the
for the confusion so it's not a hippo
right it started off as a regular
grunfeld
but then magnus decided to put his
knights on e2 and d2 which is not normal
not necessarily normal in the setup
although it's not bad
now the knights have prospects right
this knight could jump out to f4
this knight could later go on to f3 it's
not like these knights are locked in
place
magnus could also try to get some queen
side pressure going with b4
but mbl and and nakamura having the most
developments right now
nakamura has decided to take with the
king on
f7 not the rook the king fulfills now
the same role as the rook it could also
be attacked just like the rook
but king steps away if you try to open
up a discovered attack against the
knight
no problem i just defended with rook f7
i think mbl had good chances here
it seems to me that these chances are
rapidly beginning to slip away from him
unless he can create something in the
next move or two by the way knight d3
very important detail
knight d3 meets with rook to e4 if not
for this move black would end up losing
either the rook or the knight
and uh mvl could take and go knight c5
and
you know he has a symbolic advantage he
wins one of these pawns because he's
also
also threatening a fork but this is not
nothing that hicarro can't deal with
so my estimation is that this game will
be a draw
now hikaru if he manages to win today's
mini match they go to an armageddon
playoff which is in his favor he's the
better blitz player
uh but so mvl ideally would like to win
this game
uh given that he's white particularly
because
he emerged from the opening what seemed
like a very good position back to lavon
against
nepo lavon's knight is making all sorts
of jumps
oh okay so nepo did well he did open up
a discovered attack against the knight
on d5 he wanted but in return he
sacrificed the other night
uh and again look at all of these pins
now he pins the other knight
queen to c2 i mean crazy stuff does
anybody want to tell me what happens
after rook to c8 why is rook c8 not just
winning the knight on c6
there's a little nice detail here that
people have to see thank you brunei for
the prime
really appreciate it knight to e7 of
course yes
and one two attackers and only one
defender
so aronian wins a second exchange that's
not good
what does that mean that means well nepo
could consider a move such as knight to
g5
uh threatening checkmate on h3 but it's
less scary than it appears i think after
h4
white opens up a little hole for the
king on h2
you could give a check on h3 but that
doesn't really do much
sorry and whoa holy smokes chrome js10
with 10 gifted subs
this is unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable
thank you chrome js10 for the 10 gifted
subs and happy thanksgiving
yeah you're very welcome man and thank
you for the uh
thank you so much i i am tongue-tied
at this level of support
wow 10 gifted subs and joy people thank
you so much
yeah over 3 500 which we crossed
yesterday
just incredible
yep thanks for the fat 10 gifts of
pikachu
but i still maintain that we have to get
pikachu in here
um thank you mebobox well okay so back
to the game
if black moves the rook away from d8
then he gives up
b4 and by giving up before
your entire initiative has evaporated
and
you don't have enough for the exchange
and black might be losing this i i'm not
sure what nepo
really has in store for aronian here you
can take on c6 he does
that's what he did but now he's give
okay so he's trading queens and
basically what this is signaling to me
is that he's going to try to
hold on in the end game there is one
really interesting mitigating factor
which is the fact that this rook on c6
is
actually trapped if you look at this
rook it has no squares
so nepo could have a plan where he just
moves his king saunters over to d7
tries to pick off the strapped rook but
that's why aronian played rook a1 he's
trying to untie the rook by playing
bishop a3
forcing the exchange of bishops and
that's the glue that's causing black's
position to
be together so bishop a3 is quite
possible in this position
i think he's going to play bishop a3 but
what nepo is doing is
creating a hole for his own king in
order to prepare knight for so ironian
plays e3
he's he's defending the d4 square
thank you the bear jewel okay uh and
he's going to play bishop a3
well on the next move i was going to say
until nepo stopped him
but in stopping him he allows the rokin
escape route via c8
which is something that iranian might
use now or he might use it later
we'll keep an eye on this game as we
talked about
mvl against nakamura has proceeded
exactly in this fashion 93 rookie iv
now i think mbl is going to acquiesce to
the inevitable and take on e4 go knight
c5
this game is going to end in a draw
quite rapidly
but we're gonna see okay so carlson has
played h3 he's throwing that in there
to potentially prepare some g4 ideas
which gary's gonna have to be careful
about
now this is the sort of position which
it might not seem like a lot is going on
but there's a lot of tension that's
percolating under the surface
because both sides are gearing up no pun
intended gearing up
i'm hilarious um
for a potential opening of the center
with e5
so something like e5 even in this
position is absolutely possible
the center opens up the question is
always in these positions who is more
prepared
for the opening of the center is it
white or is it black that's a question
that both players have to evaluate very
carefully
yuri does have a lot more time which
tells me that he's prepared for this
for this particular setup he's chosen
where to put his pieces
well vascular against nakamura is still
a dead draw
just knight and rook and two against
knight on rook and two
with no advantage now for either side
this is going to be agreed to draw i'm
pretty sure
and carlson geary i like what anish is
doing here
at least preliminarily he's building up
his big time advantage
and he still hasn't decided to open up
the center
but what he has done is planted a bishop
on this very weak square that white has
on before
so how does carlson now manage
uh this position i think something like
knight f3 comes to mind maybe you stop
e5 permanently
but then you give up the e4 square what
should also be pointed out here is this
bishop on f5 that ain't going nowhere
girl
so you got to be a little bit careful
about accidentally not allowing g4
which would trap the bishop thank you gg
yo good good name
for the uh for the prime is c5 a move uh
c5 you've got to be very careful about i
assume you mean from black side
well then that takes on c5 well it's not
that it's a mess it's just that
yeah he's played c5 oh for white side he
does play c5 good job h wolfson
well it's it's not that it's a mess
again it's it there's two factors i
would point to here
that make this position but maybe give
give this position some clarity
the first is does is black going to play
e5 and open up the center
which side is more prepared for that the
second is this bishop on f5
is it going to come back to haunt black
or not is white going to be able at some
timely moment to play g4 and potentially
trap the bishop now that's why carlson
plays knight f3
he's stopping geary from playing e5
and yeah so c5
for white ryan says he doesn't like well
i mean he closes up the queen side
now the bishop on b4 is also stranded
now it can't be trapped because it's
protected by a pawn and there's no white
pawn that could possibly attack it at
any point in the game
even mathematically yeah bullet right
now yeah
but that's not necessarily a good thing
maybe gary plays b6 and tries to give
this bishop a passage back
we'll see uh we will see
i need to take a 10 to 15 second break
guys
um just to uh flush out my mouth but
i'll be right back
and we will continue monitoring this is
again those of you just joining us this
is the quarterfinals of the skilling
invitational it's called the open but
it's actually not an open at all because
it's featuring the greatest players in
the world of course as you can see
the winner so basically each semi-final
matchup is
a consists of two days of games there's
no
there's no easy way to explain this
because it's pretty darn confusing
basically they play four games a day and
then the winner of each
mini matchup advances so if it's one one
one person won the first days match up
other person won the second
they play an armageddon to determine who
who advances to the semis
in any case uh 95 so what
gary has managed to trade his
problematic bishop but
now the other bishop is also a problem
because it can't go back
so this is a really interesting position
we'll keep an eye on this
so we had a transformation a bunch of
trades
and carlson mopped up that bishop and
magnus is definitely better here so he's
emerged victorious i think from
and we talked about this right the
position is going to transform in some
way
and in such positions the way to follow
these positions is is always to ask
yourself okay who benefits from the
transformation here it's been white
why because look at this beautiful
protected pass pawn
number one okay fantastic number two
bishop on b2
a lot of people look at that terrible
bishop bishop is staring at the pawn
these bishops are often misunderstood
imagine if this pawn were gone from e5
i would compare this to wesley so's
bishop which was on b2 right ah
terrible bishop but as soon as he pushed
the pawn this bishop became a
game-winning piece
and so these are the kinds of pieces i
talked about this in the speed run
they have a lot of potential energy but
not a lot of kinetic energy right they
look bad right now
but the moment that the pawn is gone
from e5 this bishop becomes an absolute
killer or shall i say skiller he'll be
skilling if that's for sure
so the combination of these factors make
black's position quite difficult
not indefensible but definitely quite
difficult
now mvl and nakamura are still playing
well mvl has well hikara's given up upon
it doesn't really matter i mean there's
so few pieces on the board
that it should still be a draw i mean
knight five check i guess
and then he wins the pawn back yeah
because of king g3
well rook h3 seems to win the night but
then king g4
counter attacks black's knight check
king e4 okay it's going to be a
repetition of
moves or is it mvl is trying to to make
something happen here but he's he's not
going to succeed because
there's too few pawns remaining on the
board and nikaru eliminates one more of
them
it's time for a thanksgiving pun i think
we're all ready for it
carlson geary carlson definitely keeping
his foot on the gas pedal here
gary does have a very nice knight on d5
that's the one thing that's keeping his
position together
is the fact that he's got this beautiful
night on an outpost and the night is
completely unassailable it can't be
attacked by any puns
can't be attacked by any pieces it is
literally an eternal night as they say
in russian
and um this is uh
well maybe i was a little bit over
optimistic in evaluating magnus's
position i think white is better here i
have no doubt about that
but giri has his share of chances here
if he can keep his position glued
together the problem is magnus is so
good people want to know what magnus is
good at this is what he's good at
okay he takes a position where it's
clear that he's better but it's
absolutely unclear how to progress
and he makes it look so easy against
some of the world's greatest players
uh rook c4 bishop c5 comes to mind you
could pile up on this b4 pawn
that seems to be the most obvious plan
uh maybe we'll see rook c4 in this
position
followed by that seems like a magnus
kind of idea you could also try to
twist the knife in by playing bishop c5
bishop d6 first
that bishop would serve two purposes it
would just be on an outpost and h4
very patient he doesn't do anything yet
he first improves his position
and and he forces black to well he's
torturing black right he's he's
playing very slowly very methodically
carlson geary's still going on he has
positioned his bishop on on d6
um and we will check this on table base
after
after the round i will set this up in
table base and i will tell you guys
he might have slipped but i think he
just wondered i mean you have to
understand in these kinds of time
pressures with that kind of pressure
uh these kinds of blunders happen all
the time it's not
you know i'm not trying to scold him for
it it's just hard for me to believe
that someone a roger above caliber
misses something like that
but it happens it happens to everybody
obviously
okay so gary sacks a pawn but in return
he gets a big initiative for his pieces
i'm not sure that that's enough though
if you play queen before
92 king h2 i'm not sure where black's
going with this to be honest
i'm absolutely not sure where black is
going with this
so yeah i think queen takes b4
and and and it looks like black's
initiative begins to evaporate
yeah no i think this is losing i i think
that if black doesn't get anything here
then
remember white's got the connected
passers
carlson didn't play queen before he
played a5 huh
he's pushing his pawn instead no but he
wants to push respond to a7
as quickly as possible the intention is
completely understandable
uh but queen d1
[Music]
maybe gary goes here and then here but
what does he really want
after a6 i don't really see much going
on here for black
yeah 94
94 people are saying but if a6 what is
the idea
i guess knight d2 no but this is not
easy he's played knight e4
hmm knight takes g3 no but how is this
perpetual
no i don't believe that this can be
perpetual
this is perpetual i don't think so the
king escapes it seems
94 a6 i think let's figure out the idea
maybe he just wants to take and go queen
b3
could it be this because after a7 i know
it looks like white spawn is a lot
further advanced
but but white's queen needs to get to b7
and by the time that it gets there black
pigeon positions his own pawn on b2 and
we're gonna have simultaneous promotion
in the draw
so i think knight takes c5 might be it
uh i think he might just want to take on
c5 magnus might have screwed this one up
it looks like from what people are
saying queen before
is the winning move and magnus greedily
going after that past pawn of his
not realizing entirely that he's got
other things to worry about here
92 as well apparently makes a draw which
i believe
wow so that's a that's a pretty serious
result
if gary manages to save this that
continues to put him in the running if
he can
score one victory he would equalize
uh well if he obviously has to win
today's matchup
but if he does that's pretty serious now
i want to just be very clear here i'm
sitting here in my armchair
drinking my tea feeling good and
you know excoriating magnus for not
finding the stuff i mean these players
are are putting themselves out there
it's
this isn't like oh my god how could
carlson miss this it's a completely
understandable intention to push his
pawn to a7
for god's sakes the man wants to promote
but
you know magnus in so far as he's had a
little bit of
a you know insofar as he does have an
area where some people have tricked him
and he can be prone to getting tricked
sometimes in these kinds of positions he
can get tricked
and and i've seen that on a couple of
occasions so he's still the legend he's
still the best
but but he can get tricked tactically in
some positions
what if bishop okay so gary has done it
he's done it he's found it and this is
going to end in a drop
ladies and gentlemen yeah magnus is
definitely overrated now white's got to
be a little bit careful i think magnus
just has to make a draw he's got to play
a7
and he's i'm sure not happy with himself
here i think he's realized it
okay
he's gone a7 yep and queen a2 is what
we're going to see here i think
and let me pull up the other games in
the meantime
nakamura mbl
and let me set up that position as we
see
queen b1 check not sure if that was
strictly necessary i'm sure it doesn't
ruin anything
queen a2 yeah so he wants that he wants
to make sure he's making contact with
the pawn on f2
anish yeah he's solid i mean gotta give
it to him the man is very solid
he knows how to make draws and uh that's
no easy matter against someone like
magnus
okay do you enjoy seeing other gm's play
yeah i mean i really enjoy
g4 magnus uh is he entertaining
prospects of playing for a win
has he not just gotten what is he doing
what if h takes g4 what is the point of
this does he want to go h5
he wants this doesn't he he wants to get
the queen into g5
and then to d8 that is very interesting
i'm not sure about this but
he definitely this is a typical idea
i've seen this before
now i've seen this before now what is
the way to understand this is
this pawn on a7 right he wants to
promote it with tempo so
to do that he's got to get black's king
onto the back rank
deliver a check on d8 and then promote
his queen
and in order to do that he's going to
have to break up
black's pawn shell around his king so i
think this is his idea and gary's got to
be careful if he moves his king
up for example to try to stop queen g5
then magnus goes queen e4 check and
again he achieves the same effect of
promoting his pawn
before black has promoted his with a
minute and 40 seconds let me tell you
gary is peeing his pants here
i mean when you're facing magnus and he
plays a move like this
uh you're not celebrating the fact that
magnus is tilted
you're nervous as hell gary can also
ignore the soul endeavor and just play
b3
that doesn't seem too stupid either
takes takes
and i mean b2 i mean that that seems to
be the most straightforward but geary
does take on g4 i think h5 is going to
follow it does
and uh again the point of this is to
break open the defenses
surrounding black's king so that white
can try
to get his queen to a square where it's
simultaneously checking the king and and
controlling the promotion square of
white's pawn white white is trying to
promote first
i'm sure this is still a draw but let's
see how gary handles this queen e3 i
think is going to follow
i can almost guarantee you you're about
to see queen e3 on the board
and maybe black needs to yep there we go
and maybe black needs to move his king
away
but where does he move it right again if
he moves it to h7 that's a blunder
if he moves it to g6 that's a blunder
maybe he needs to move it to the back
rank just to escape the immediate check
but now he gives this check and then
this
check and again this is uh very very
dangerous for black
because if he allows a promotion there's
going to be hell to pay
okay so i hope this is making sense to
everybody again
it's all about priorities ladies and
gentlemen you might look at this and say
oh my god magnus is giving up these puns
why is he doing that well again the
priority for white is to promote his
pawn
if that means giving up three pawns so
be it
he doesn't care about the pawns here he
cares about giving the king a check
so that the promotion square is also
covered and he's
giving up anything to make that happen
gary with 20 seconds let's see if he
finds the defense
counting down queen a5 so the idea of
this move
the idea of this move is to open up the
f8 square
so that the queen will not have the d8
square which is one of the golden
squares so to speak that's a square from
which the queen is checking the king and
covering the promotion square
i think that's a very strong defensive
move
i think that's a very that's a very
strong debunk
magnus can drop just by giving a bunch
of these checks
because if geary tries to escape then
queen h 8 is going to win
or if he tries to escape to e7 then
queen f6 is going to win
because he's going to start mopping up
the pawns i actually can predict guys
that this is how the game is going to
end
i predict that magnus is going to
acquiesce to the draw here go queen h6
and we're gonna see perpetual with king
ga queen g5
it's going to be a draw and a good
effort by magnus in the end
finding every last chance but giri
staying on his heels
and finding the key defensive move
erroneous nepo has also ended in a draw
there we go when does gary object to a
draw well here of course gary has no
choice and the game is officially ended
in a draw
what a what a full round of action
let's set up the aronian so position
on table base i'm setting it up in chess
space ladies and gentlemen
this position that's in front of you i'm
setting it up in chess space
and it's white to move or sorry it's
black to move
and let's see opening up turning on
stockfish
it is winning yeah it's winning you guys
are right
but rajaba if the fact remains had a
draw and the way to win this
i know people are very smart when
they're looking at table base but
it is winning ah this is very nice
actually would a wesley have seen this
idea i think you probably would have
yeah this is winning so basically the
idea is
you you bring the king up to to f4
remember that if as soon as black takes
on h3 he allows a check on h5
uh and if black continues to shuffle
then white just pushes his pawn
and and he pushes his pawn and he pushes
his pawn
and then the key move is to play rook to
g5 which which
simultaneously defends the pawn and cuts
the black king off from further advances
so now you go here and
the game is over king f6 now i wasn't
projecting the chess-based screen
so very very nice effort by wesley but
or java with that key miss so let's open
up the games from the third
yep and mvl nakamura have already
started
so no rest for the weary
okay so uh we have i think the same line
that we had in game
one of today's match up which is this
sort of
nador with bishop g3 nakamura shuffling
his bishop all over the place the mbl
going h5 which is a very typical move
in these types of night off positions
he's actually going for some king side
attack
with h4 and uh this is really
interesting i don't know
i don't know if the opponents are still
in their preparation i'm pretty sure mvl
is
mbl of course one of the knight or
specialists of the modern day he's
he's one of the greatest specialists of
the night or
probably ever but particularly in in
today's era
he's incredibly well prepared also the
same goes for the grunfeld
so it's not bishop b4 if you notice that
the queen is x-raying the knight
the queen is x-raying the knight so i
think the simplest is to play bishop h6
attack the royal can attack the knight
you always have to watch for the x-rays
you always have to watch for those
x-rays because they can open up they can
be the keys to delivering a discover
check
mbl has taken and that's exactly what's
happened bishop sorry nakamura has taken
and
bishop d3 has been played now mvl could
take on d5
right there's no bishop h6 but there's
other moves here
uh you could even go queen to b3 and
look at black's king black's king is
super weak
uh because mbl has pushed his pawn out
to h4
and if this knight leaves then again you
look at the x-ray pawn is immobilized
crunch bishop takes g6 black's king's
position collapses rook in the land on
cesar this is a horrible position
and and igaro just you you can't get
these positions against him this is one
of his strengths
when he gets a position like this where
he's he's just pressuring like this he
just doesn't let you go
i'm anticipating something like rook c6
queen b3
such easy play here for white on top of
everything else
we have a berlin in the game gary
carlson not interesting
let's check back into the game nakamura
against mvl as predicted
total disaster this is going to be a
quick win for nakamura
mvl is now down in exchange which he was
forced to sacrifice because
white was just skewering the hell out of
black here on f7
mvl desperation time um
mvl desperation time looks like it works
guys
so nobody caro can trade queens here if
he wants he can go bishop g5 more pins
pins galore he can just defend the
before pawn white is spoiled for choice
this game is all but
over mvl is a great defender but even
for him yep nakamura just says all right
i'm gonna defend the pawn on b4 i'm not
gonna let you capture it
i'm not gonna let you capture it and uh
white can then
smoke out black's rook with rook to a1
on the next move
yeah a a very strong performance here by
by hikaru for sure
who's going to be go on to win today's
mini match against zambia and they're
going to go on to an armageddon
they're going to go on to an armageddon
but okay maybe i should do some
impressions a little bit mano here we
have a
sicilian okay let me try to do
an impression of a player
that is playing the game and try to
evaluate the position there is a blitz
first so well i'm again and it's
what i call blitz playoffs the same
thing blitz blitz
sorry guys the format is so confusing
now
here we have sort of like a sveshnikov
type position
where white's got control over the d5
square but black's got mitigating
factors your black's got queen side
pressure so this is still
well within theory but i think that
wesley has got to be happy with the
result of the opening
because the last game of course i got a
little bit lucky and i wanted to thank
timor for
losing on time but here after h5 h4
it's not well here for sure white is
slightly better because i have control
of the d5 square
but after bishop h3 maybe you want to
trade the bishops
and then put a knight on d5 but
we'll see what the more the more place
here now the clocks are not working so
let me refresh the screen
one more time i apologize for the
technical problems here
but let let's go with um gary against
carlton
um what do you want do you want me to to
win the game
right after the opening is is that how
you play a smooth game
and murray says is that what you want
from me i mean is that how you play the
berlin defense
come on come on
bishop f5 all right uh i can't really do
magnus so i'm sorry
that's the one that's the one weak spot
i have uh now we have a berlin here i
don't want to cover this game if you
guys don't mind
um i i really don't want to cover this
game because it's a berlin and i hate
the berlin
um and we have a donation three bucks
from
uh river riven techno says some no don't
worry river tecmo
uh i've done i've been doing impressions
for over a year i
because of the community that i have i
think everybody knows i respect the hell
out of these people
and i mean that in the truest sense of
the word so
uh we all gotta laugh we gotta have some
fun and guess what i invite everybody
to make an impression of me in fact i've
made an impression of myself so if i'm
making fun of myself i think
uh then it's it's permitted but thanks
for your uh concern i think we'll be
fine
uh all right guys uh is it okay if i go
to sleep to this position
now it's a berlin how do we understand
the position let's get serious about
this i am supposed to be commentating
so um okay so let's let's invite gary
you know to describe to us you know how
exactly you know to look at this
position you know
first of all you know i i reminds me
know the game is kromnic that i played
in astana in 2000
uh one of the main sort of things to to
realize the brilliance
pointing 16 years is the main idea you
know
in these types of positions you know so
white has to consider you know
what happens you know if he sticks here
and and and
and okay bernie sanders you know hillary
clinton you know donald trump you do
you talk about politics you know
vladimir putin but after e6 you know
it's not so clear
um um
yeah but yeah because i've heard him
more in a political context recently so
i can imagine how he says the names of
like
politicians but it's harder for me to
imagine him talking about chess thank
you mcsrp for the prime
sorry for the tier one
well uh thank you gary for the
impression
uh now let's uh well my name is
vishyananda let's take a look at
the game after h3h6 well
[Music]
well i think uh by and large uh magnus
um
he knows how to play these positions but
uh
well i think that um he will be able to
draw
uh this position but uh
okay f36 uh well uh black is in some
trouble here but uh gary
giddy with 15 minutes plus i think after
bg4 and
h5 i think well uh it's definitely
improved but
uh yeah uh
i'm pretty pumped at this okay so let's
go back to nakamura mvl hikaru
continuing his demolition here
he's up in exchange he's got the pass
pawn running up the b5
now the material advantage itself is not
that vast he's
well mvl is only down in exchange but
with almost no pieces left on the board
uh well this is quite bad again the
board is frozen okay let me here's what
i'm gonna do folks
here's what i'm gonna do um because i'm
so sorry about this i'm quite
embarrassed but i'm not sure
why this happens i'm not sure why this
happens
uh it's never happened to me before on
this scale for some reason the
screen capture gets messed up when i
change to another screen so
i'm not going to use chess space let me
just close chess base
i'm not going to use it because it
messes up the screen capture
yeah you need to refresh each time you
change shaft so i'm just gonna stick on
this tab guys sorry about that i think
it happens every time i use chest space
or another screen
uh but it's okay now what is hicara
doing here he is counter attacking the
d6 pawn so if black plays queen takes b5
then knight takes d6
and white is just winning here so mvl
doing a good job resisting he's got over
10 minutes he's a little bit tilted here
it seems to me he's tilted
he's got over 10 minutes which means
he's played fast and he hasn't played
very well
not to take anything away from mikaro
who's played a stellar game
gt xyz so we'll keep an eye on
that game as we check back into gary
carlson which despite being in berlin is
heating up
man man man this game is heating up
ladies and gentlemen
now in the berlin it's very important to
understand that black's king i know
that's a banal statement but black's
king has moved
so if you guys are why can't black just
castle here he can't move his king he's
already moved it by capturing white's
queen
which means that strictly speaking
black's gang is in some danger
carlson could go c5 to defend i mean his
pawn is also being attacked here that
has to be understood
so he can go either c5 the other move he
could play is c6 right to defend the
pawn on t5
what is the drawback of the move c5 the
drawback is that if you look at this
pawn on d5 very carefully
this pawn on d5 is going to be weak why
is that important because
white could use it as a pawn no pun
intended no pawn intended man
all these puns these meta puns pawns uh
in order to open up the d
file and he can use the default as a
vehicle perhaps as a ferrari
gtxyz to get to black's king
okay that was a good couple of sentences
right there yeah
okay so black is in some trouble here
i'm not sure i'm a big fan of magnus's
position
i think that he should play c6 i think
that you should try to keep this pawn as
well protected as
possible in order to keep the d file
closed i think that's the best way for
him to hold the balance here
probably the position is still equal i'm
sure if you turn the computer on
which i never do by the way because i
despise commentating with computers i
think that's a travesty and i wouldn't
be doing my job as a commentator if i
had the evil bar on
because then why would anyone need me um
not that anyone needs me in the first
place
but just for those of you who are
surprised i don't have the evil bar on
i think and this is just my opinion i
respect completely people's
commentating practices there's a lot of
great commentators out there
and they have different styles of doing
it but for me personally
the you know having the eval bar on or
having the computer on
it doesn't make it fun for me it doesn't
make it fun for anybody
you know part of the fun is in trying to
understand the essence of the position
trying to get deep into the position
trying to explore understand the
mistakes and when you just have that
metallic eval bar on
it somehow kills the intrigue for me
personally
um and i appreciate that people are uh
that people are on my side here i really
appreciate that and
another before as before the games heat
up as magnus does in fact play c6
just wanted to say how much i appreciate
all the support
in the last months but today this
morning we had
tons of incredible donations i'm very
happy we've got over a thousand viewers
that is a lot more than i expected
uh happy thanksgiving to everybody and
uh
whether you're in u.s or in europe uh
just wanted to to extend my appreciation
at you taking time out of your busy
mornings or afternoons
to watch the commentary i'm having a
great time and remember i always
welcome any kind of feedback
constructive criticism if you want to
send me a message on twitch
i do read them i don't respond to
everybody just because i'm
flooded with all sorts of communication
but i try to read
everybody's opinion so thank you guys we
are watching the skilling
so-called skilling open it is day two
of the quarterfinals uh the players are
playing two mini matches and then the
winner of that advances to the
semifinals we have two more games to go
this ongoing one and then one final one
so
uh we're going to be following things do
we have do you have two monitors no
now that i'm right home usually in
charlotte i have two monitors right now
i have a laptop and then an ipad
so it's it's it's the next best thing
but uh it's not quite
the same as two monitors and here we see
c3 now by giri he's defending his own
pawn on c2
advancing it to c3 and after e f takes
e6 we're probably going to see either
knight takes c6 or rook to e1 maybe
he'll try to pick that pawn off with a
rook
although i don't really know i think
this is going to be a draw
ladies and gentlemen breaking news anish
geary
is about to make a
draw this is a historical event ladies
and gentlemen
historical i i'm speechless i'm
tongue-tied
so i think after a night of fate white's
only attempt to generating some winning
chances might be to go after that b-pawn
but uh and again modern made a joke like
this i think
just take a sip of tea
well magnus is definitely under pressure
100 bits always streams thank you so
much i'm very happy to hear that man
magnus is definitely under pressure here
no doubt about that but he has held this
together very
nicely i think geary's gonna take on fa
we're gonna see a draw in this game i'm
pretty sure
and um we're gonna see it draw no screen
is not frozen guys
have you ever had a job outside of chess
no
um i considered well i applied for a lot
of internships
both my sophomore and my junior years of
college and i
got rejected from virtually all of them
so
and i'm also in love with chess so i
could not be thinking of doing anything
other than what i'm doing right now
mostly consulting i applied i applied to
a bunch of consulting internships
um and not that i deserve to get in
because there's a lot a lot of
candidates a lot worthier than i am
so it's fine i respect that i did choose
to major in history that's perhaps not
the best major to
develop career prospects but no regrets
i'm doing what i love
do you give private lessons yes that's
my main main thing
okay mbl back to mvl yep nakamura has
won
as we predicted okay so this was a
resounding victory now um with a nice
move rook c7
and promoting his pawn making a second
queen and winning the game isikara
nakamura he has officially won
day two of the match against mbl mvl won
yesterday's matchup so they will go into
a blitz playoff that'll be a cintilating
affair
we will keep an eye on that mvl is white
in their first blitz game i believe they
played two blitz games
i believe they play uh
two blitz games to decide the match
if somebody could confirm that i would
be very appreciative geary just drew
with
magnus carlsen yep so
that game is going to move on to game
four and gary is going to have to win it
but i don't think that's going to happen
so it looks like magnus will be
advancing
okay so we got another one of these
italians we've seen this structure
many times we've seen the structure many
times here we have a bishop against the
night situation
now as i discussed earlier what's very
important in such a position when you
have a pass bond is who's got control of
the square
in front of the pass pawn and here of
course
white doesn't really have control
because he doesn't have a knight to put
on d4 but nvl centralizing his pieces
bringing everything in
looks like a pretty peaceful position i
think white is slightly better here i
don't think there's any doubt about that
icaru could maybe snag the pawn on a2
but mbo could very quickly then start
pushing his pawns up to f6
to e6 that kind of stuff could get super
nasty so maybe he car just wants to
eliminate the bishop on d3 except a
slightly worse position try to defend it
and we're gonna see
i've got a lot of eyes
okay um rook to d2 yep that's what
nakamura has done he's taken the bishop
he's gone queen b6
and um yeah nabil on fake here i guess
that was mvl they just
changed it and what is mvl's idea he
wants to quickly create a past pawn with
f5 and e6
f5 and f6 is also possible to try to
weaken black's
king's side
so let's see i'm anticipating the move
f5 ladies and gentlemen by mvl
hikaru can then try to get his rook to
e4 to intercept
the coordination between black's pieces
yeah i mean i'm not sure exactly who
is on top here i feel like white's the
one playing for an advantage i
really have no doubt about that but
in a blitz game anything can happen at
any moment here comes f5
no i didn't catch a mild cold it's just
that i'm talking a lot and
i need to catch my catch my breath every
couple of moments rook to c2 by hicaru
going after blacks going after white's
pawns this makes a lot of sense
now mvl could consider i would
centralize the queen with queen d4 just
defending the pawn
i think it's too early for something
like e6 ikaro's idea
is this rook on c2 combines with the
other rook
uh and and and black i think has enough
counter play here to make a draw
f6 by mbl he is going right after
black's king this is going to get
really interesting this is going to get
really interesting
how will he car respond to this he's in
some trouble here he's got to be very
careful
okay wesley and rajab by the way
looks like wesley is once again pushing
for a win
okay yeah but then but then black will
have some perpetual ideas rook takes b2
by
fg i don't actually love mvl giving up
this pawn i don't think that was
necessarily
obligatory rook to d4 comes to mind but
then rook to b4
stopping the rook from getting to g4
okay
let's see what mbl does here my guess is
mbl should take on g7
expose black's king and then maybe go
rook to d4 i think white's still calling
the shots here
but ikara was so confident in these
positions he
he sees everything in these types of
positions and mvl dipping on the clock
yeah so we'll see how he does nepo game
is crazy apparently
let me see yeah nepo game is absolutely
wild i don't know what's going on here
aronian and nepo jesus total madness
here in the board
between aronian and nepo mvl has gone
queen to f3
so he's going to g4 he's going after
some lobster pins or made
ideas very interesting i'm not sure it's
good though
in fact i think it might not be good
because
well the idea is if rook takes a2 right
let's say hikaru takes
then queen to g4 g6 and boom e6
right crunching through black's defenses
but what can i do
hikaru can maybe go rook to e8 that's
what i'm thinking
queen g4 g whoops sorry queen g4 g6
and if you go e6 now then black has
enough defenses on that square
to be able to ward off white's
initiative white ends up a million pawns
down
so i'm not sure if i if i like the move
queen f3 i feel like mbl might be
letting this out of his control
but goodness me aronia nepo is just
absolute
madness again we'll keep an eye on that
but that's not the important game right
now
we gotta keep an eye on the important
games ikaro is settling into a deep
think he's now below three and a half
minutes he's lower on time than mvl
that could become significant of course
this is the blitz playoff the best of
two
advances to the semi-finals queen to c5
is interesting suggested by demon to tie
down white's queen to the palm but
remember
white also has access to that d-pawn
icaro has of course found the move rook
to e8
i'm pretty sure this is what mbl had
missed
now if anyone's in trouble it might be
mvl
we'll see rook to d5 maybe um not again
it's it's a crazy position it's
anybody's game
i would take on d5 if i ramble trying to
open up another front
we'll see no i don't think that icaru is
is worse at all actually so let's turn
on magnus's game also
geary against magnus
oh magnus is still playing game three
isn't he
let me see did it get interesting
gary carlson game one sorry one sec i'm
just trying to find it there's so many
things here oh yuri
no it's a draw i think yeah
this is a draw so i can at least try to
maintain order f takes g7 by mvl cutting
into black's king position
he's decided to take on g7 what if your
car just takes on a2
i'm not sure what mvl has in mind here i
think icaru can just take on a2
okay um
i'm not again just not sure what mbl is
doing here
gary carlson is officially ended in a
draw
okay so mvl and nicaragua two minutes
each and the all defending the e5 fund
he's gonna go after now but this is
anybody's game
this is going to get wild ladies and
gentlemen seat belts fastened and
mandatory
best of two they are playing blitz to
decide the outcome of the match
amvio with the white pieces he cannot
afford to lose this game
if he loses this game with the white
pieces well
winning against cicara with black on
demand is all but impossible
okay now hikaru going rook c2 he's
deploying the rook either to c4 or to c1
every trade is good for black gear
obviously because black's king
is the one that's under fire nbl has let
this go completely he had a great
position
but i think he was a little bit
overzealous in how he approached
the attack easy for me to say he's the
one playing under the lights and then
pressure
this is very very complicated
nonetheless
also let's not forget ikaro is the one
who holds the connected password so any
transition to an
end game would be most probably
disastrous for white
rook f4 could be a move yeah you could
go after the pawn you could go rook to
e3 maybe to stop
black's rook or queen from getting to c3
that's another nasty little square
which could force a queen trade and
indeed
mvl has gone rook to e3 as we predicted
but he's below a minute and a half
hikaru below two minutes will hikaru
just go sorry
will hikaru just go a4 and start pushing
his pawns that seems
like a very viable strategy i'm not sure
where mvl's attack is going to come from
because if you move the rook to f4 what
you might also allow is the move to d4
forcing the queen trade rook to c4 rook
takes d5
grabbing the pawn and here comes hicarus
pawn with a4
okay what's the pawn count the palm
count currently is actually equal
believe it or not huh
now what should mvl do in this position
one crazy idea would be to go king to h2
just getting the king out of the line of
fire he's done it
king to h2 not so crazy after all my
idea
was something like this queen to f6
sacrificing the rook trying to go around
to h8
and deliver checkmate this move would
not have been possible to king on g1
because there would have been the
checkmate b5 that's what's happened
will mvl go queen f6 i came up with this
idea thinking it would never happen on
the board it's happening right now will
then be able to queen f6
is this a very strong move or is this
just something crazy if you take the
queen then i play e takes f6 thank you
solar paid
and then you cement the pawn on g7 if
rook takes e3 rook d8 is going to be
checkmate
mvl has i can't believe it this actually
happened
i can't believe this actually just
happened
wow okay now what will hikaru do again
the idea ladies and gentlemen if he
takes the rook
then queen takes h6 made on h8 seems all
but unstoppable maybe f6 but
i really don't believe this check on e6
at the very least
this why was king h2 necessary imagine
if the king were on g1 ikara would have
a check on c1
followed by checkmate on h6 i think
hikarus missed this he's below a minute
what will he do
what is the defense if he ignores white
entirely then rook d6 shuts the queen
and queen takes h6 to follow
this is really really interesting a
beautiful concept
come by mvl here under a minute on his
clock hikaru dipping below he's got 40
seconds he's got to find something what
is there in this position
i'm not looking at the evol this is
incredible stuff
what to do what to do is black winning
is white winning it could be anybody's
game here rook to c1 some people are
indicating he car has done it
but what if e6 in this position looks
like black is winning no but now queen
takes c6 at the very least and rook
takes b5 is at least gonna be a draw
and mvl has gone rooked f3 ho
what is this rook to f3 queen to d5
queen h6 f5 maybe is going to happen
this is absolute pandemonium it's
anybody's game
20 seconds for hikaru what to do in this
position ladies and gentlemen seat belts
fasten and mandatory hikaru with rook h1
check
he's forcing the king onto a square
where the queen could deliver check on
f3 what an idea
any caro is winning i think because of
queen h6 and queen f3
and then black isn't white just doesn't
have enough firepower here after f5
although i don't know king h1 f6 queen
h8 and queen takes the 8 is gonna happen
followed by a promotion but he car is
probably winning here e6 by ambeal no
ha i think white's winning now oh my
goodness
oh my lands e7 mvl's gonna win e7 and
mbl is gonna win
queen 81 is impossible what a turnaround
what a finish we'll take a look at this
and nbl has
won the first game against the car what
an incredible finale
because there's no stopping the pawn
incredible finale
in this game e6 was the move overlooked
by hikaru
and he should have gone what should he
have done he's already losing here
queen takes h6 and he's losing and wow
he should have probably just taken the
queen and gone before something like
this
and it's anybody's game but ikaru
blundering in the end the move
incredible movie six an amazing effort
by mvl
an amazing effort by mbl and
hikaru in now a must-win situation with
the white pieces in their second blitz
game
and if mvl is able to save it then he's
going to win the match
the counter is still going but it's a
1-0 this game is over because
well black can try to push response but
he's going to get checkmated obviously
and mvl pulls it off
not easy to win a game like this ikaro
clearly in good form he's finding a lot
of cool ideas
but so is mvl as we will monitor
their second blitz game let me see